depuis dix jours l'ambiance de la sortie
des classes et pesant à l'école
maternelle de la chênaie à genlis un
enseignant remplaçant est suspecté
d'attouchements sur l'une de ses élèves
de moyenne section
une petite fille de 4 ans l'alerté a été
donnée par ses parents
le 16 novembre dernier la petite fille à
un moment donné a dit des choses qui
bien évidemment a interpellé ses parents
qui ont amené les parents à lui poser
quelques questions et à entendre de sa
part des faits qui pouvaient laisser
penser qu'elle avait été agressée
sexuellement au sein de l'école et par
son instituteur l'enseignant mis en
cause a été suspendu de ses fonctions à
titre conservatoire dès le lendemain
cet homme de 42 ans marié et père de
famille est un ancien directeur d'école
élémentaire en côte d'or qui a fait le
choix de rejoindre une équipe de
remplaçants
il intervenait à genlis ponctuellement
depuis le mois de septembre
il n'a aucun antécédent judiciaire
l'enquêté se poursuit et une cellule
médico-psychologique a rapidement été
mise en place à l'école
mais cette affaire a plongé dans le
doute tout les parents d'élèves c'est
quelque chose d'inacceptable donc c'est
bouleversant en tant que parent en tant
que maman c'est quelque chose que
j'accepte pas donc c'est vrai que ça
nous a tous retournés après il faut pas
les interroger les enfants donc c'est
vrai qu'on les laisse dire on les
surveille on fait attention par rapport
au changement du comportement s'il ya un
changement ou pas s'ils ont pu envie
d'aller à la douche
donc c'est vraiment là actuellement
c'est vraiment de la surveillance quand
ma fille rentrer tout de suite le
premier truc que j'ai fait je sais
qu'elle adore dessiner et des enfants ça
c'est votre beaucoup au niveau du dessin
je vais dire prends moi une faille un
stylo des six mois dis moi elle m'a
dessiné un toboggan j'avais dessiné des
poissons la dessiner des poissons
quelque part ça m'a rassuré parce qu'il
n'y avait pas eu je pense qu'elle aurait
dessiné tout tout de suite quelque chose
qui leur est choquée moi j'ai mon petit
neveu qui était dans sa classe jamais
rien rapporter de particulier je sais
pas du tout après une garde à vue
prolongée le professeur des écoles a été
mise en examen pour viols et agressions
sexuelles sur mineur de moins de 15 ans
par personne ayant autorité
pour ces faits la peine encourue est de
20 ans de réclusion criminelle
pour l'heure l'homme est placé en
détention provisoire